Let's
go.
I've titled this lecture revelation uh
revolutions, tyrants, and wars. It
sounds like a terrible title, but that's
exactly what it's about.
I saw a woman sit upon a scarlet colored
beast full of names of blasphemy.
Revelation 17:3. Here is this church
controlling this scarlet colored beast.
Revelation 13:4 says, "And they
worshiped the dragon
unknowingly, of course, which gave power
unto the beast, and they worshiped the
beast, which has been defined as that
power which ruled for 1,260
years, then received a mortal wound, and
will rule again at the end of time." And
we have identified it basically as
Catholicism.
And they worshiped the beast saying,
"Who is like unto the beast? Who is able
to make war with him?" Yeah, they're all
bowing down to this strange beast, the
kings of the world and the high people
of this planet. They pay homage to it.
They worship it through their obedience
and by giving them the power of the
state to deal with any issue.
Here is an interesting uh quote from
popery puzzism and Jesuitism.
At what then do the Jesuits aim?
According to them, they only seek the
greater glory of God. But if you examine
the facts, you will find that they aim
at universal dominion alone. You see,
Rome had lost universal dominion and the
Protestant Reformation had been a major
problem in this issue. A major problem.
They have rendered themselves
indispensable to the pope who without
them could not exist because Catholicism
is identified with them. They have
rendered them indispens themselves
indispensable to governors and hold
revolutions
in their hands. And in this way, either
under one name or another, it is they
who rule the world. You see, the papacy
has crowned itself ruler of the entire
world. The pope is the ruler of the
entire world. That's the Holy Roman
Empire spread over the entire planet.
Well, if we have a look at a century of
revolutions starting from 1750
to 1850,
we'll see the American Revolution in
1776.
And we can ask the presidents that then
ruled who do they think was respon were
responsible for this revolution. Then
there's the French Revolution 1789.
The Spanish Revolution 1823, the Polish
Revolution 1831,
the German and the Italian Revolution
1848. By 1917, you had the Russian
Revolution. And then basically it was
time for war. 1914 to 1918,
which made the Russian Revolution, by
the way, possible. And World War II,
1939 to 1945, that's a lot of conflict
on this planet. How much blood did not
flow on this planet as a consequence of
these revolutions? And why? Because one
power wanted absolute control. And the
Bible says the dragon gave it its power
so that everybody should be subject to
that power and to none other.
Well, let's have a look at a brief
chronology here. In 1717,
we're dealing with this time period of
terrible, terrible confration on this
planet. The Masonic Grand Lodge of
England was founded. England was a thorn
in the flesh. It was a Protestant
nation. So, a Masonic Grand Lodge is
founded to infiltrate
this power. 1721, the first Masonic
lodge was founded in France.
1731, Benjamin Franklin was initiated as
a Freemason.
1738, the Roman Catholic Church condemns
Freemasonry. Now, that's a brilliant
move. That's called dlectic thinking.
You create an organization, you ban it.
Your insiders belong to the
organization, but the outsiders see that
you have distant yourself. It can't be
your fault. You see how clever that is?
Whereas at the Vatican all the lodges
remained and all the cardinals were
members but not the goyam. It was to be
a Protestant army under the control of
the Jesuit order and we did an entire
lecture on that and you can get it uh
the one on who's behind the secret
societies.
By 1758 Sir Francis Dashwood found the
Hellfire Club. Benjamin Franklin visits
England to discuss the future of
American colonies with Dashwood
1768 foundation of the right of strict
observance. That's the 33 degree level
of Freemasonry by Baron Fonhunt based on
the Template tradition. So that's an
interesting point. And then Frederick of
Prussia, Frederick the Great, I don't
know what was so great about him, but
nevertheless, founded the order of the
architects of Africa and uses the title
Illuminati
to describe his NeoMasonic lodges. So
that's just a brief history as we're
going along. 1770
Benjamin Franklin was elected
grandmaster of the nine sister lodge in
Paris.
1771 Grand Orient Masonry was founded in
France. 1776 Order of the
Perfectibilists or Illuminati was
founded. Notice they call themselves
perfect.
The American Revolution starts. So by
1776 they had put everything in place.
1778 Peter I founded the secret circle.
1785 Grand Masonic Congress allegedly
plotted the French Revolution. The
Illuminati was banned in Bavaria who
went underground there. 1789 French
Revolution 1784ist
conspiracy to overthrow the Hapsburg
monarchs of the Holy Roman Empire. So
the monarchies must go. The monarchies
were often opposed to uh Jesuit rule and
they banned the Jesuits. Well, it was
payback time. Nobody bans the power of
the Roman Catholic Church.
In 1816, John Adams wrote to President
Jefferson. Shall we not have a regular
swarms of them here in as many disguises
as only a king of the gypsies can
assume? Dressed as painters, publishers,
writers, and school masters. If ever
there was a body of men who merited
eternal damnation on earth and in hell,
it is this society of Lyolas. They
didn't mince words in those days, eh?
Wow. That's the New Jesuits. There's the
the quote. Everything I say has got a
quote. Now, many writers warned of this
great conspiracy of the Jesuits. Samuel
Moss, remember the founder or the
inventor of the Morse code, wrote, "The
author undertakes to show that a
conspiracy against the liberties of this
republic, the United States, is now in
full action under the direction of the
wy prince Metron of Austria, who knowing
the impossibility of obliterating this
troublesome example of a great free
nation by force of arms, is attempting
to accomplish his object through an
agency, an army of Jesuits.
The array of facts and arguments going
to prove the existence of such a
conspiracy will astonish any man who
opens the book with the same incredul as
we did. So those are the people that the
presidents believed were behind all
these conspiracies. President Abraham
Lincoln himself said, "The Protestants
of both the North and the South would
surely unite to exterminate the priests
and the Jesuits if they could learn how
the priests, the nuns, the monks, which
daily land on our shores under the
pretext of preaching their religion are
nothing else but emissaries of the Pope
of Napoleon 3, who was a high Freemason,
of course, and other despots of Europe
to undermine our institutions, alienate
the hearts of our people from our
Constitution and our laws, destroy our
schools, and prepare a reign of anarchy
here as they have done in Ireland, in
Mexico, and in Spain, and wherever there
are any people who want to be free.
That's quite a statement.
50 years in the church of Rome, the
priest, Father Chiniki, wrote, he used
to be a Catholic and then became a
Protestant. This war would never have
been possible without the sinister
influence of the Jesuits. We owe to
popery that we now see our land reened
with the blood of her noblest sons.
Abraham Lincoln 1865 16th presidents of
the United States Lincoln's private
letters they were burnt by his son
Robert restated by Charles Chiniki who
was the personal confidant of the
president.
In a letter dated 22
January 1870, Msini wrote to Pike. Now
Albert Pike is this highmason who wrote
this the manual if you like of Scottish
Freemasonry.
He said the following. We must allow all
of the federations to continue just as
they are. It must appear as things are
as they were in the beginning with their
systems, their central authorities and
diverse moes of correspondence between
high grades of the same right organized
as they are at present. But we must
create a super right which will remain
unknown to which we will call those
masons of high degree whom we shall
select. With regard to our brothers in
masonry, these men must be pledged to
the strictest secrecy. Through this
supreme right, we will govern all
Freemasonry, which will become the one
international center, the more powerful,
because its direction will be unknown.
Now Albert Pike wrote a letter to
Mancini and that was dated August 15,
in which he propagated that there should
be a world order a one order where all
nations are under the control of one
central organization and in order to
achieve this they planned and there are
numerous quotes for this. So I've put a
number on the screen because some will
say I don't trust this I don't trust
that I don't trust the other. Here are
references down there. There are
references up there. There will be
references in other slides. So it comes
from different sources. He said, and
this was, by the way, on display in the
British Museum and could be seen there
until it was taken away. The first world
war to overthrow the power of the SARS
in Russia, protector of orthodoxy and
bring about an atheistic communistic
state. Did that happen?
>> Yes. Now, that was written long before
this event.
Long before this event, this was written
in 1871.
This war broke out in 1914.
The Second World War that's also written
long before the event to originate
between Great Britain and Germany to
strengthen communism as a as anti-thesis
to the Judeia Christian culture and
bring about a Zionist state in Israel.
Did it achieve this objective? Yes. In
fact, after this war, Israel in its
present form was reinstated under the
protection of Britain.
And then, interestingly enough, a third
world war, a Middle Eastern war
involving involving Judaism and Islam
and spreading internationally. That's
fascinating. Is that uh on the cards?
What do you think? Certainly sounds like
we are on track. Well, here's another
quote uh just in case people don't like
that quote. Msini with Pike developed a
plan for three world wars so that
eventually every nation would be willing
to surrender its national sovereignty to
a to a world government. The first war
was to end the Saris regime in Russia.
The second to allow the Soviet Union to
control Europe. The third world war was
to be in the Middle East between Muslim
and Jews and would result in Armageddon.
Interesting.
Now, how were they going to do it? Let's
read what Albert Pike wrote about these
wars and uh how they were going to be um
unleashed. He wrote, quote, "We shall
unleash the nihilist and the atheist."
So the destroyer and the atheist and we
will provoke a formidable social
cataclysm which in its horror will show
clearly to the nations the effect of
absolute atheism.
Origin of savagery and the most bloody
turmoil. Then everywhere the citizens
obliged to defend themselves against the
minority of revolutionaries
will exterminate these destroyers of
civilization. And the multitude
disillusioned with Christianity
will receive the pure light through the
universal manifestation of the pure
doctrine of Lucifer. The destruction of
Christianity and atheism both conquered
and exterminated at the same time. Wow,
what a clever plan.
So you rub the two systems which you
create up against the other. You create
atheism as an anti-thesis to the
Judeo-Christian culture. You have these
two clash until they rub each other up
and then out of that you will get a new
world order where you have a new
religion which is far more esoteric and
actually honors Satan. Isn't that a
rather clever plan?
Well, it's very successful.
That is why oro abcao oro abcao
is the
the
verse if you like that uh freemasonry
uses. This is one of their documents
remember that I photographed in a
masonic lodge. And vice is the father of
jaccoubinism. You will remember that we
spoke about that in Revelation 11. And
Jacobinism was the power that propagated
the French Revolution. And we did this
in Revelation 11 where the Bastile was
stormed. Liberty leading the goddess of
reason was enthroned instead of
Christianity. So Christianity was
removed and another reign began. Uh the
monarchy was deposed
and Louie and his wife lost their heads.
The beheading of Mari Antoanet and that
put an end to that monarchy.
Then Rabispier he headed the Jacabine
clubs and a reign of terror commenced
which in its bloodshed and its violence
rivals anything that we have seen to
date. The great philosopher if you like
of the French Revolution was Voltater.
Now you can look it up in any
encyclopedia Britannica. They will tell
you who Voltater was. He was a Jesuit.
They will say of course he was a
renegade Jesuit that left the Roman
Catholic Church to write against it. No,
no, no. He was just playing the role
perfectly
because they were setting up an
antithesis. Do you remember the promise
that a Jesuit makes that I will take
either side and do it perfectly as long
as in the end the mother church wins?
Well, to hold the pen is to be at war.
The social contract man is born free and
everywhere is in chains. One man thinks
himself the master of others but remains
more of a slave than they are. That's
true. But what if you created the
slavery in order to create the misery,
in order to create the revolution? Isn't
that possible?
So the philosophers come together and
they write a new constitution for this
planet called human rights. The
declaration of human rights 1798
declaration human rights. You have the
allseeing eye of Lucifer. You have the
serpent with a tail in the mouth, the
lifegiving serpent, the eternal serpent.
And you have this funny little jaccoine
hat over there on the end of the spear.
If you look at the whole thing over
there and then you have this bundle of
rods tied together which are called what
do you remember what they were called?
Fasci
fasci
bundle of rods tied together and on top
of the fasci you have this funny little
hat which was the jaccoin hat and that's
what it looked like. There's a better
representation
of also known as the Friian cap once
worn in ancient Rome by emancipated
slaves as a mark of their freedom and
adopted in the revolution as the red cap
of liberty. Well, that's what they tell
you. That's for the goyam.
Let me tell you what it really is. There
it is. This is the god Mitra.
And there he is slaughtering the bull.
And he's using a dog, a snake, and a
scorpion which has got part hold of the
more delicate parts of this bull. And
he's destroying him with unclean
animals. This is a war against Christ.
Now, let's have a look on the side. What
does his hat look like?
It's the frigian hat. So, this is
Mitraism.
And Catholicism is Mitraism. Mitraism
was the religion of Persia. It was the
religion of Rome and it is the religion
of the Roman Catholic Church. There are
seven grades in Mitraism. The highest
grade is called father.
And then you got a congregation. Now who
in the Catholic church has a
congregation and is called father? The
priest, right? And he could be a member
of various groups and so can Catholic
priests. They can be whatever. They can
be Jesuits. They can be um Franciscans.
They can be Dominicans. They can be
members of various other orders as well.
So Cyrus the Great was the first one to
bring out the human rights charter. Now
the mortal wound as we had discussed it
in Revelation 11 just to refresh your
memory. 21 February 1798 Pope Pas is
dethroned by Napoleon. His ring was torn
from his finger and he died in exile.
Now think about this. If Napoleon was a
Freemason, then he was under control of
whom?
Of the Jesuit order.
So who sent Napoleon to Rome to take the
Pope captive?
The Jesuit order. Why?
Well, I've thought about this a lot.
Within the Roman Catholic Church, there
are numerous orders and there has not
always existed perfect harmony.
In fact, the Jesuit order slowly slowly
took control of all the orders. The
Knights of Malta, for example, did not
lightly give up their power seat, but
are now subject to the Je Jesuits. The
Dominicans
were at loggerheads with the Jesuits.
For example, the papacy took the
Inquisition away from the Jesuits and
gave it to the Dominicans, which created
tremendous tension. And in the French
Revolution, it was the Dominican order
that was destroyed there, not the
Jesuits. They controlled the issue. So
there were some issues within the church
itself that also had to be sorted out to
get complete control of the situation.
It was even so that at the council of
Trent many a Roman Catholics stood up
and said the word and the word alone.
Don't think that everything in the
Catholic Church has always been negative
towards the word. No. And Martin Luther
must have made an impact as well. And so
there were many that weren't in line. So
the church itself needed a purging. Then
there was another problem.
And this problem was this that the
reformation had fingered Rome as the
antichrist. Now if the reformation
fingers Rome as the antichrist, any move
that seems to emanate from Rome will be
looked at with what? Suspicion.
So why not destroy the papacy apparently
and then resurrect it with and at the
same time purge it of everything that is
contra and then resurrect it as a final
power in complete control of these
organizations. Does that make any sense?
That would be a neat trick. And then
anything that happened thereafter with a
weak little papacy over there would be
disregarded. It cannot be from them. It
must come from elsewhere. That is how
secret societies work. They walk behind
fronts, behind fronts, behind fronts. So
let's see what happens. By 1804,
uh pas watches Napoleon crown himself
emperor. Napoleon then takes the Vatican
state. So Rome is diminishing. By 1848,
Masini attacks Rome and Pope is exiled.
Papal states are gone. So this power is
gone. The Protestants literally relaxed.
Basically dangerous thing to do. Bertier
takes the pope captive.
Vice Halped and his fellow Jesuits cut
off the income to the Vatican by
launching and leading the French
Revolution, by directing Napoleon's
conquest of the Catholic Europe, and by
eventually having Napoleon throw Pope
Pius the 7th in jail at Avingong
until he agreed, note, as the price of
his release to reestablish the Jesuit
order. It had been banned even in the
Catholic Church. Imagine that. So it had
worked underground
this Jesuit war. Or maybe it had been
banned purposefully to make it seem as
if there was a war. You never know
because these people are superb liars.
But this is history. This is what
happened. This Jesuit war on the Vatican
was terminated by the Congress of Vienna
and by the secret 1822 Treaty of Verona.
There's the quote. Everything I say has
got a quote. I'm not making anything up.
After Pope Pius was released from
Napoleon's prison, he formally restored
the Jesuit order with a papal bull. Now
that is the strongest worded statement
that a pope can bring forth in 1814. And
the pope added in this bull, if any
should again attempt to abolish it, the
society of Jesus, he would incur the
indignation of almighty God and of the
holy apostles Peter and Paul. So this
could have been a ruse. It could have
been a game. what could have been real,
whatever the situation is, we will never
really know until the curtain is removed
one day. But religious freedom for all
and uh revolutionaries take to the
streets and do what they feel they have
to do. Joseph Bonaparta here he is 1768
1844 king of Spain and he was
grandmaster
grand orient in France. So here you have
all the Masonic connections. This come
from the Masonic book Masonic sources.
Napoleon himself a high Freemason is now
waging war in the whole of Europe
cleaning up the monarchies and then he
has a war with England. Now who controls
England by this stage?
The Freemasons. So we have a battle of
Waterloo and these are the generals that
fought on the two sides. Michelle N and
Eon Crouchy. They are on the side of
Napoleon. Hi Freemason. Hi Freemason.
Napoleon. High Freemason. On the other
side you have General Bla. Those who are
German will know a statement that goes
on
which means you know general blick at
the river Katsbach he gave Napoleon
blazes. Hi Freemason and Gon
Schnarenhost high Freemason they were
all Freemasons.
So this war
was it really a war or was it a planned
war? Now who are the orchestrators of
the first world war? Well, there he is.
Kaiser Villhan the first. What has he
got on? This comes from a Masonic book.
He's got his Masonic apron on. He's a
high Freemason. That's what he was. Here
is Kaiser Friedri deer. There he is with
his Freemason regalia from a Freemason
book. They're proud that these kings
were all Freemasons. So, the whole war
situation is being planned by Freemasons
who are being run by who? By the
Jesuits.
Now let's have a look at America
quickly. Here is this grand building,
the Capitol. There is the foundation
stone and it says laid masonically
September 17, 1932.
Okay. So by that time, America was ruled
by Freemasonry. Of course, the people
are totally unaware. The institutions
continue as before, but they are all
being infiltrated. If you look at the
the uh architecture, the eagles, the
symbolism, what you have is sun worship.
You have mitraism displayed here. The
street plan of Washington is masonic.
You have the upside down goat of Mendus
in the street plan. Then you have the
compass and the set square and
everything is in blocks of 13 and the
Masonic temples are on the 13th street
etc. The whole street plan of Washington
is masonically laid. So it's dedicated
to Lucifer.
Of course, the people are unaware of
this. The White House is then built with
this tremendous stellar over there. The
height of which is 555 ft. Not 666. That
belongs to someone higher in Rome. This
is 555.
And uh isn't it interesting that 555 is
the number that Hollywood uses? Have you
ever heard when they say what's the
telephone number on any TV program or
any one of those? Oh, it's 555 blah blah
blah blah blah. Have you heard of that?
It's dedicated to Hollywood. By the way,
Hollywood, Hollywood is the wood they
use to make a witch's staff. So, it's
dedicated to Lucifer. It's witchcraft.
But that's just besides the point. So,
here is the stellar.
Who laid these foundations? The
Freemasons. So, let's ask them what it
means. Here is the encyclopedia of
Freemasonry. You going to get a better
source than that. Obelisk were
originally erected in honor of the sun
god. The connection comes from the
Egyptian worship of the fallus. So,
there stands a male whatever in the
White House. So, we don't have to go.
It's dedicated to Osiris and to Isis.
And uh anyway that is the structure over
there. The military structure is a
pentagon
which is the high center of the
pentagram into which for example 13
witches would step in order 12 around
one in order to propagate a curse. So
this is also a witchcraft structure. So
it's just a building, but it has certain
connotations. Then France, the one that
has this new philosophy for a new world,
sends a gift to the United States, the
Statue of Liberty. So let's ask UNESCO
what it means. UNESCO says, "The seven
rays emanating from Mitra's halo,
there's the god Mitra,
uh, symbolize the triumph of the forces
o over the forces of darkness." Now you
must understand that Lucifer says that
Michael and his angels represent the
forces of darkness that Yave is the
devil. Isn't that terrible? You remember
that we did that? And here UNESCO tells
us that the head of the Statue of
Liberty is adorned with Mitra's seven
rays. The flame she holds is a sun
symbol. So this is the tors of Lucifer
because it doesn't matter whether
Lucifer is male or female. He's
androgenic in uh his story. Here is the
foundation stone at this site on August
5, 1884. The cornerstone of the pedestal
of the Statue of Liberty enlightening
the world that's illumination
was laid with ceremony by William
soandso, Grandmaster of Masons. And
there's the Masonic sign. So the Statue
of Liberty is Masonic. Everything will
appear to be Masonic. As we continue,
text Mars writes, "Twowering above the
shimmering but polluted waters she holds
in her outstretched arm and her hand the
torch of fire and light, a gift of the
Masonic order, the modern inheritors of
the Illuminati heritiage of the Statue
of Liberty was sculptured by Frederick
Baraldi, a member of the Masonic lodge
of Alsake Lorraine in Paris, France. The
statue is significant to the secret
societies plotting the new world order."
There you go.
Right. By 1854,
pas declared the immaculate conception
of the Virgin Mary. Now Mary is being
she's always been there in Roman
Catholicism, but now Mary is being
placed into the very center and
legitimized as the mother of God and as
an entity in heaven.
In 1869, Pius summons the first Vatican
council and in 1870 the dogma of papal
infallibility is published. Now we have
another god on earth and ultra montanism
triumphs. The Jesuits see to it that all
power is concentrated in one man.
What happens then? By 1917, the Russian
revolution and you had this interesting
Fatima message. There's a link with
Islam there, but never mind. We'll come
to that in the next lecture. Russia will
be converted. The Holy Father will
consecrate Russia to me. And then there
was a vision of hell. And the third
vision was that the present pope would
have a assassination attack which
happened. Now it's not too difficult if
you've planned all these things from the
beginning to say what will happen. You
see not too difficult. Now let's have a
look at the parallels between the Jesuit
French and the Russian revolutions. They
worked like this. Both revolutions were
based on communist writings of
Freemasons. Voltater marks. The Jesuits
perfected communism on their reductions
in Paraguay. So in Paraguay they tested
whether this would work or not and
perfected it there. Both revolutions
plundered the state churches.
Both revolutions ended the monarchies.
Both the Burbon and the Rammanaf
dynasties had expelled the Jesuits. Both
of them were gone. They weren't going to
take this chance again. Both revolutions
re produced republics in form but
absolute monarchies in power controlled
behind the scenes by the people that
were now in control. Both reol
revolutions declared atheism as the
religion of the state. Both revolutions
carried out a reign of terror by an
inquisitional secret police. And boy was
that some reign of terror. Millions
millions died. Stalin is personally
responsible for the death of millions of
people.
Both revolutions resulted in military
dictators responsible for the
elimination of dissenters. Exactly the
same pattern. If it works once, why not
use it again? The lesson learned on
these Platonic republics there in
Paraguay provided the groundwork for
Marxist communist manifesto by which
every nation on earth would be reduced
to granny reductions
thereby destroying the white Protestant
middle classes while restoring the
communal feudalism of the papal Caesar's
dark ages. That's just a quote. Well,
it's a bit sharp but it more or less
sums it up. So KL Marx by 1844 wrote the
the communist manifesto. That's when he
wrote it. That's when it was published.
1848.
By 1928, papal nunio in Germany leads
the Catholic powerful center party to
the right and helps skyrocket Adolf
Hitler to power. Now who's Adolf Hitler?
By 1929, pious disbands the Catholic
party. It's done its job and people are
ready to vote. And in the same year he
crowns himself sovereign ruler of the
world. What arrogance. Now the pope is
sovereign ruler of the world. In the
same year he signs the documents. Now a
ruler has to have a country and he gets
his papal state back. The smallest state
in the world.
And the papacy now again qualifies as a
political entity. Now it had been dead.
It was no longer a political entity. So
the beast was mortally wounded. And now
it gets its power back. And now it
qualifies as a beast again. Its wound
was healed. Isn't that correct? That's
why the San Francisco Chronicle almost
quoting the Bible says that while they
signed this document, the wound was
healed in this display. Now we're ready
for war. 1934 in Yugoslavia. An
organization called the Ustachi is
formed. What a disgusting organization
founded and they assassinate King
Alexander of Yugoslavia. Now the Istachi
is a military organization with
basically Nazi features and they
slaughtered the Serbs. They slaughtered
the Orthodox people and forced them to
become Catholic or to die. one of the
two and nothing is ever said about this
tremendous slaughter that took place
over here. 1941 Croatia declares itself
independent and the slaughter begins.
This is the man who is now Pope Cardinal
Secretary of State Eugene Pateli.
There is his family. All of the Masonic
connection
and of course they have the bank de
Romano at their disposal with Rosschild
money. This man does he have Masonic
features? Yes. Here he is at his
election. His cell number was 13. A very
important number in Freemasonry.
There he is in the Masonic triangle
stamp that they produced. There he is
with the Masonic sign just as Anthony
Seya had it. And something else from
then on the pope papacy wore the
ephodont the little plaque that was also
worn by the priests of Israel. Now let's
ask Albert Mackey, a 33 degree
Freemason, to quote to us what this
means. He says
the grand high priest of the royal arch
freemasonry from 1859 1865 in the USA
states in his standard work this is him
states that the high priest of the royal
arch officially wears the ephod. So
who's the high priest of freemasonry?
There he is the pope.
Well, Patelli visited the United States
and conversed with this man, President
FD Rousel. Now, this is a large picture
with which should never probably have
been released, and they're probably very
upset that it has been released, but it
shows Roushelt in his full Masonic
regalia.
And there it shows him with his fairs on
his head, and he's receiving
Masonic handshake. Note the Masonic
handshake and uh interesting fears. We
will come to that in the next lecture.
What that all symbolizes, why they are
wearing fees.
And uh he appoints Myron Taylor as
special envoy to the Vatican. Now let's
have a look at the Freemason political
leaders in the United States. And I'm
just quoting from various sources and
web pages. There will be different ones
here so you can check it out for
yourself to show you just who's control
at the moment. We'll just run through
them quickly and see what degrees they
are. Bill Clinton 33 degree. New King
Gingbridge 33 degree. Bob D 33 degree.
Jack Kemp 33 degree. Storm Thurman 33
degree. Colin Powell 33 degree. Jesse
Helms 33 degree. Barry Goldwater 33
degree. Al Gore probably 33 degree. Then
another one over here. Another one.
James Monron, Andrew Johnson, James
Garfield, McKinley, Rouserfelt, of
course, William Taft, Franklin
Roosefeld, Harding, Lyndon Johnson,
Gerald Ford, Ronald Reagan, George Bus,
all of them. Yak Rabin, Yasa Arafat,
Prince Philip, Duke of Kent, many
others. Here's another source. Saddam
Hussein, that's interesting. We'll have
to come to him. 33°ree Freemasons.
Tony Blair, 33 degree. Gat charreda
prime minister of Germany if you like
president 33 degree Benjen Netanyao 33
Yasa Arafat 33 degree Ronald Reagan
Gorbachov helmwood call Shimon Perez
Helm Call is also committee of 300
France Miton 33 was grand orient lodge
of course Jitsakarbin Villibbrand all of
these old ones were freemasons some more
Joseph Stalin he was Illuminati he was a
member of the grand Orient Lodge Leon
Troski Grand Orient Lodge Kishinger is a
member committee of 300 Jed Cahoover 33
Cel John Rhodess Alistister Crowley Walt
Disney was a 33 degree Freemason Olive
Palm Al Gore Tony Blair Joseph Mangala
that's interesting that's the mass
murderer of the Nazis he was Illuminati
Robert McNamara you name it they're all
there Billy Graham oops sorry let's move
on Colonel John Glenn Buzz Aldrin
everyone who's ever up in space has to
be a Freemason of the highest degrees.
Edgar Mitchell uh all the way through
Frans Bacon, Lord David Owen, all the
negotiators, Richard Halbrook. I'm just
running through some of them. Alan
Greensprang, Peter Wallenburgger, Queen
Elizabeth is the queen of the builder
burgers. Prince Phillip, Queen Beatrix,
she's the committee of 300. Prince
Bernard of the Netherlands committee of
300. And so we go on and on and on and
on. Ted Kennedy, Rockefeller, David
Rockefeller, Ting Huie, Baron
Rothschild, Hillary Clinton, his six
grand dam. She's a very high Freemason.
Albert Pike of course you know Bertrand
Russell Ottoon Hartsburg vice hop all
the way back.
Here is Ed Gahoo. President Dwight D.
Eisenhower there honors him with the 33
Grand Cross at the special white house
ceremony. They're not ashamed of any of
this. Here are
just about all the presidents of the
United States in the presidential
gallery of the lodge. I photographed
this myself. I went into the lodge. I
went into the presidential gallery. I
photographed each one of these
and then
me not me. Anyway, there they all are
as Freemasons. If we look at the
American dollar, some very interesting
things happened under the time of
Roosevelt.
There is this symbol on the dollar.
There's that symbol. We haven't got time
for all of this. In God we trust one. Uh
if you look at this symbol over here, it
says I knew it kept us nollorum. If you
intercolate the hexog, then you'll have
this as nom, which is a scrambling of
mason mason. If you go to the other
side, it points to objects and it then
reads arto. You have arlington. Ah,
there's too much there to talk about and
many interesting things. If you go to
the one and you go to the half moon,
there's a little structure over there.
Can you see it? It's a micro dot. You'll
have to get a magnifying glass and look
at it under a magnifying glass and
you'll see it's a little owl. A little
owl. Owl in a half moon. And this over
here you'll see is a spider's web.
There's a lot of symbolism over here.
Now, if you go to the ancient coins, you
will see that the deities were
associated with the owl. And you will
see that when we went to the Bohemian
Grove, what did they worship there? The
great owl of Bohemia. And you saw the
presidents of the United States bow down
to the owl of Bohemia. Quite a scary
business. Now looking at this symbol you
have the allseeing eye of Lucifer. It is
not yet on the base of the triangle.
When it is placed on he will have his
kingdom. But that is Lewis Lucifer Anu
Copus he God no clllorum new order of
the ages. There are 13 levels over
there. The bottom one is the date of the
founding of the the independence of the
United States. But it is also the
founding of the Illuminati. You have the
spider's web symbol of the new age. You
have uh over here the band the ribbon of
Lucifer. You will see it over here in
this Roman Catholic church where you
have Anubis, the fernex
symbol of Jupiter, the god Jupiter and
the skull and crossbones. And there you
have the ribbon. You see it associated
with Jupiter. That's on the flame. And
all of these symbols tell us one
interesting story. On the other side,
you have this symbol. There are nine
feathers. There are 13 spears. There are
13 leaves. There are 13 pentagrams
shaped in the form of a hexog. You have
the eagle. You have this statement over
here unum. out of many one. We're going
to reunite all nations. So that's the
symbolism of a new world order on the
dollar. The world is going to be united
under one central government and that
government is going to be in control of
Lucifer, not Jesus Christ. Although
Jesus Christ of course knows about it,
permits it and is ultimately in control.
He tells us ahead of time that this is
going to happen. And then the end of the
story is that Jesus will reign on this
planet.
In the previous section, we were looking
at the symbolism on the US dollar and we
saw how all of this symbolism is masonic
and appeared on the dollar lot after the
time of Roushelt.
Revelation 13:11. And I saw another
beast coming up out of the earth and it
had two horns like a lamb and he spoke
like a dragon. We're going to deal with
this prophecy in detail in another
lecture. It exercises all the authority
of the first beast which we will find
will be Roman Catholicism before it and
causes the earth and those that dwell in
it to worship the first beast whose
deadly wound was healed. So here was now
a Protestant ally that would enforce
papal doctrines but that's in another
lecture complete lecture called two
beasts become friends. If we look at the
architecture even it is interesting that
is St. Peters that is the capital
building. The architecture is identical.
Of course the building itself was
designed the American one by Freemasonry
and Freemasonry is in control
by whom? The Jesuit order. Now let's
have a look at some of the symbolism
over there and some of the interesting
issues. We are now ready for the Second
World War. And the three main role
players of the Allies are this man over
here, Winston Churchill. And he was a
what? 33 degree Freemason. We saw
Roushelt in his full Masonic regalia. He
was a 32 or 33 degree Freemason.
And then we have Stalin who was of
course Grand Orient member. So 33 degree
Freemason. They're all on one side.
Extract from a report by Ambassador
Harimman in Moscow to the State
Department June 30, 1944. Stalin paid
tribute to the assistance rendered by
the United States to Soviet industry
before and during the war. He said that
about 2thirds of all the large
industrial enterprises in the Soviet
Union had been built with United States
help or technical assistance. The other
third had been Britain. So who built the
United uh the USSR? Who built it? The
West. The West financed it and built it.
Here you can see Winston Churchill in
his Drew Masonic lodge with all his Drew
fellows around him. So these are genuine
facts. This isn't just conjecture.
Do you remember Pearl Harbor?
Well, fortunately the 50 years of
secrecy act are for are passed and so
now we know for a fact because this has
been revealed that they knew that Pearl
Harbor was going to be attacked. Is that
correct? And they chose not to do
anything about it. Why?
Because they needed an incident to start
a war. The American Constitution was not
going to permit them to enter a war.
They needed an incident and they created
it. In fact, that is mass murder of
their own people. Is that correct?
Because they knew about it. This is
public knowledge. It's in the news. The
50 years secrecy is up. Nobody can deny
it anymore. It's a fact.
So, America once before has killed
thousands of its own people
to allow something to become possible
that wasn't possible before. Once done
successfully, do you think they could do
it again? I wonder what about the other
side, Hitler.
Hitler said, "I learned much from the
order of the Jesuits until now. There
has never been anything more grandiose
on earth than the hierarchial system of
the Catholic Church. I transferred much
of this organization into my own party.
The SS was constituted according to the
Jesuit principles. Himmler, head of the
SS, was closely associated with the
Jesuits through his father and brother.
Hitler said of him, "I can see Himmler
as our Ignatius of Lyola." And Joseph
Gerbles was also a trained Jesuits. So
the two sides, who controls them both
the same parties? This is called thesis
anti-thesis.
Gbles, Himmler, these people were
Jesuits. They were fascists.
Adolf Hitler fascist using the symbolism
of the sun god. The Maltese cross, the
symbols of the sun god. Here he is with
uh Hindenburg himself, of course, the
Freemason. This thing is all entirely
planned. Gaining the youth on his side.
One of the principal Catholic
personalities to help Hitler to power
was France Fonin and France Fon of
course leader of the Catholic party
helped to skyrocket Hitler to power. So
the Catholic Church skyrocketed Hitler
to power. And these are posed pictures.
They have Masonic meaning, but we'll get
to that later. the Reichkes Adla chosen
as the symbol, Masonic symbol and uh the
supposed happy alliance in the beginning
which then deteriorates. Here you see
the salute with the Masonic uh
activities associated with it. Here he
is together with the church leaders and
here you can see the cardinals giving
the Hitler salute. So the church was
very much involved with the Nazi
movement. There is a bunch of cardinals
giving the hyitler salute. The pope and
the furer. You will recall that even to
this day there is tremendous anger about
Pope Pas having now being declared on
his way to saintthood because of his
connection with the Nazi movement.
Well, here is the new Reich Bishoff
Lutvik Müller, the Protestant one who
greets Adolf Hitler with a nice
handshake. The previous one, the
previous Protestant bishop no longer
lived because Adolf Hitler had him
executed. So, this one must have been a
puppet on the religious side. So, the
Catholics and the Protestants next to
each other. Now, understand the wall.
Let's think about the war. Who is the
problem in terms of the Roman Catholic
Church
firstly? The Orthodox Church in the East
had been a problem. The First World War
sorted that out. The Tsar had been
removed
and the Orthodox Church had been
subjected as were all the churches to
make it look right by
atheistic communism.
But the leaders of communism were all
Catholics.
In fact, I have traveled in many of
those countries and the people, the old
people all told me, "Now we understand
why the leaders of the communist
regimes,
why they all attended the Catholic
Church? Why, if they were all atheists,
were they such good Catholics?"
Well, this mighty army is built up, but
Germany is divided. The north of Germany
and particularly the east of Germany is
all Protestant. They're Lutherans
and they are skeptical of the papacy.
Whereas the south of Germany is all
Catholic.
In the orthodox countries like the
entire USSR, you have the orthodox
church controlling the mindset of the
people. Now since the takeover of
communism that has been reduced or
subjected and the orthodox church has
been subject to the states
now comes this mighty wall. The symbols
being carried here are the symbols of
Lucifer. They're also used in theosophy.
There you can see them. There's the
swastika, the allseeing serpent. And
Adolf Hitler himself was a tremendous
occultist.
Of course, as a Jesuit insider, he would
be, but of course his outer garb of
religion was Catholicism. You'll find
the same swastika on the foot of Buddha.
And as I recall, as I told you before,
it was a Jesuit priest, Fatherfl,
not Hitler, who really wrote Minecomf.
So a Jesuit wrote the book. The SS has
the same symbols as the skull and bones
people. The skull with the crossbone
to my honor means
to be
loyal. Loyalty. The SS had been or
organized by Himmler according to the
principle of the Jesuit order and became
basically the new if you like
inquisition and anybody who did not obey
the system was destroyed. Now we read
much in the literature about six million
Jews who were destroyed. But we read
nothing about two and a half million of
the most brilliant people in Germany.
All the professors,
all the intelligent, highly educated
Germans who were killed by Adolf Hitler.
You see thinking people cannot be
tolerated in such a regime. downgrade
the mindset. We must have surfs and
elite goyan katakum cattle and then the
super illuminous. How irritating.
Remember that the Jesuit magazine severa
house organ of the Jesuits says quite
frankly fascism is the regime the regime
that corresponds most closely to the
concept of the church of Rome.
Fascism is fascinating. Excuse the pun.
Fascism has one central leader. You see
pope eventually one central leader, one
central leader, total control over the
people. Yet the people believe that they
are free because they are getting
everything that they require. Unlike
communism, they may have property
rights, but the property rights are
qualified. And I'll come to that in a
later lecture in case you are duped into
that. Now here are these fii. Let's have
a look at them. The bundle of rod
accompanied by an axe or a spear which
symbolized power over life and death
carried by the Roman official as symbol
of authority under the republican
conflict or pitia. Starting on an
expedition he took his vows on the
capotulin hill where the Vatican sits
today. This is very symbolic. He a
claimed if acclaimed emperator in other
words leader by his troops he decked his
fussy with a laurel and on his return
deposited the wreath upon the capital
line hill. Everything leads to Rome.
Fascinating story. So where you find the
fasi you must know that Rome is behind
it. Fascist regimes use the fasci. So
fasci can look like that with an axe or
the axe can go through or it can be a
spear like it was in the French
Revolution. These are fasci. Now where
do we find the fasci? Well in 1888
campaign poster of incumbent President
Grover Cleveland uh Benjamin Harrison
defeated them but later he won Cleveland
was re reelected to a non-consecutive
term. There his ego is standing on two
fasi. See it fascism hidden in the
United States. Do you know the the
United States should be as far as the
east is from the west from fascism?
Isn't it?
Well well well. Isn't that fascinating?
The US capitol building. If you go right
to the tippy topy that's what you have.
Fasci fasci fasi. Fasi.
So the United States eventually is going
to become a fascist state.
Nobody would have believed that
50 years, 100 years ago, 10 years ago,
maybe not even five years ago. Today,
what does it look like?
Is there mighty state control over every
single one just like in the times of the
SS? If you move, is there a new uh law
coming out which will watch the people
of the state? Yes or no? Yes. Patriot
bill. Have you heard of that? All kinds
of interesting laws coming out. Now,
what type of government is that?
Interesting. There it is. Did you know
that the fasci
fasci behind the rostroom podium of the
House of Representatives in Washington
DC? Note the back of the chair resembles
a golden axe. There it is. The axe and
the fasi. So they knew this all along.
They're just waiting for the
opportunity, biding their time. Ancient
Roman coins with the fasci. Here is a
fasci dime in America with a flame
there. Fasi on a US dollar and
presidents sitting next to fasci is
Washington. Even Abraham Lincoln sat on
a fasi chair. is the insignia of the L
national guard. It has fasci
fasci and the statue of liberty. Let's
read what Anthony Sutton remember this
man who wrote about skull and bones
educated at the University of London
Gottingham California research fellow
Hoover Institute. This is an important
man. Let's see what he has to say. How
the order creates war and revolution.
talking now about skull and bones which
is the Illuminati which is the Jesuits
behind the scenes as we have seen
operational history of the order can
only be understood within the framework
of Hegelian dialectic process Hegel the
great man who said
always create two directions thesis
anti-thesis
rub them up against the other who cares
how many people die in the process then
you have synthesis is then you get what
you actually want from this axiom. It
follows that controlled conflict can
create a predetermined history. For
example, when the trilateral commission
the submit managed conflict etc. We read
this quote before so I'll just skip it.
The synthesis that's which comes
together sought by the establishment is
called the new world order. Without
controlled conflict this new world order
will not come about. Random individual
action of persons in society would not
lead to this synthesis. It's artificial.
Therefore, it has to be created.
So you hear about a war here and a war
there and a revolution here and a
revolution there. Revolutions have to be
financed.
You never hear where the money comes
from to finance them. Who finances the
revolutions? Who runs them? You see? So
you have Nazis against Soviet unions,
North Korea, North Vietnam, and Nauseium
against the United States. The conflict
built profits while pushing the world
ever closer to a one world government.
Now, isn't it logical that that's what
Satan wants? He wants a one world
government.
So in Hegelian philosophy, the conflict
of political rights and political left
or thesis and anti-thesis in Hegelian
terms is essential to forward movement
of history and historical change itself.
Have you noticed that every country has
a left party and a right party? Have you
heard about that? And your country has
it too otherwise there would be no point
to vote, right? Two of them.
Now let's have a look how this is
worked. President Woodrow Wilson made
this statement. This is now president
speaking. Some of the biggest men in the
United States in the fields of commerce
and manufacturing know that there is a
power so organized, so subtle, so
complete, so pervasive that they had
better not speak above their breath when
they speak in condemnation of it. Aha.
So here is a power that controls things.
Kmak and thus capital posed capitalism
as thesis and communism as anti-thesis.
Now you'll have Jesuits clamoring for
capitalism and you'll have Jesuits
clamoring for communism.
The clash of oppositists must in the
Hegelian system bring about a society
neither capitalist
nor communist. That's synthesis.
Moreover, in the Hegelian scheme of
events, this new synthesis will reflect
the concept of the state as God
and the individually as totally
subordinate to an all powerful state. If
you don't do what the state says, sizzle
fits.
That's what Adolf Hitler practiced. Two
and a half million Germans sizzle fits
gone.
What then is the function of parliament?
Now, take note. I'm not saying this. I'm
reading it. I get criticized for this
statement. You cannot believe. Please
don't criticize me. Write to these
people. I'm just quoting.
What then is the function of a
parliament, a congress for Hegelians?
These institutions are merely to allow
individuals to feel that their opinions
have some value and to allow a
government to take advantage of whatever
wisdom the peasant may accidentally
demonstrate.
All right. Now, let's see how Hegel puts
it himself. This is now the great
philosophic for Hegel where the
politicians bow down to him. He says,
"By virtue of this participation,
subjective liberty and conceit with
their general opinion, individuals can
show themselves palpably palpably
efficacious and enjoy the satisfaction
of feeling themselves to count for
something. In other words, we're just
idiots.
So if you vote, who you voting for?"
I'll tell you who you're voting for. I
always say this, they vote for the devil
in pink or the devil in blue.
The vote makes no difference. It's a
joke.
Politics is a joke.
War, the organized conflict of nations
for ageliumism is only the visible
outcome of the clash between ideas. As
John Dwey, the Hegelian darling of
modern education system puts it, he's in
control of the whole new world
education. War is the most effective
preacher of the vanity of all merely
finite interests. It put an end to the
selfish egoism of the individual by
which he would claim his life and his
property as his own or as his families.
Did you get that? Now surely Rome
doesn't think like that. Oh, I'll show
you papal bulls which will make your
hair stand on end. New ones.
Compare this to the spirit and letter of
the constitution of the United States
which says absolutely the opposite. All
right. So for these elitists the state
is supreme and a self-appointed elite
running the state acts indeed as god on
earth. The rest are katakummans cattle
goyam. College textbooks present war and
revolution as more or less accidental
results of conflict. But then never
never in western textbooks will you find
the evidence that revolutions need
finance and the source of the finance in
many cases traces back to Wall Street.
Operational vehicles for conflict
creation. The key to modern history is
in these facts. The elitists have close
working relations with both Marxists and
Nazis. They play on both sides because
what they have created is just a game.
In this memor memorandum, we will
present the concept that world history
certainly since 1970 reflects
deliberately created conflict with the
objective of bringing about a synthesis
a new world order. So let's have a look
how it worked. Here's the order. The
thesis is Marxist Russia second world
war.
The antithesis, Nazi Germany.
Who financed them? Who financed the the
Russians? Guarantee trust company. Who
financed the Nazis? Guarantee trust
company. And then you have Harimman,
formerly of Haramman and Company, etc.,
etc. Same people over here. Harimman,
Nazi interest. Same people finance both
sides. Then you have the Bolevik
revolution 1917 and 1933. Hitler's
ascension to power, conflict between the
two, tremendous profit, and the result
post World War II United Nations as the
first step to a new world order. There
you have it beautifully financed by the
same sides. By 1948, the atomic race. By
1950, Mary receives pilgrim status.
1950, Francis Matthew calls for nuclear
war with Russia. And they start arguing
between the two of them. Notice how many
were killed by Stalin
among the 1,766,188
victims up to the beginning of 1922.
Figures obtained from the Soviet
documents, nearly 5,000 were priests,
teachers, nuns, etc. of the Greek
church.
As soon as the persecution extended to
the millions of Lutheran, Reformed,
Baptist, Methodist, and especially
Menanite Christians, the circulation of
the Bible is not only strictly
forbidden, but punishable by exile. So
that's what Stalin did. Stalin killed
millions. We hear of six million Jews.
Well, think in terms of 30, 40, 50
million people when you think of Stalin.
the greatest mass murderer this world
has ever seen.
And Foster Dalith's President Kennedy,
what is the story there? Well, here is
Kennedy and he's married to this young
lady, Jacqueline Kennedy. And they are
setting up the United States for a
tremendous
conflict in the end. And every president
has to play the game. Eventually, this
president dies
and this one takes over, Lyndon Johnson.
But did you know something interesting?
A president has to swear on the Bible
when he takes over. Did you know that
Lyndon Johnson refused to swear on the
Bible? What did he swear on? Lyndon
Johnson is swear in as president by
Judge Sarah D. Hughes just hour after
the assassination. Judge Hughes brought
a small Bible for the swearing in
ceremony, but it was substituted for a
Roman missile mass book that was found
on the plane.
So, he swears on a Roman missile. He
refused to swear on the Bible. Doesn't
that tell you something? Isn't that
interesting? I find that very
interesting. Now, why did that president
have to go? He was a Roman Catholic
after all. Is it possible that not all
Roman Catholics are so easily duped?
Here's the motorcade as it travels
along. Here you have Mrs. Kennedy helps
the Secret Service agent Clint Hill
climb into the car at the back when the
president was shot. And uh here are the
roses she received.
Very interesting. Here is Dallas
11:22. On November 22, 1963,
John Fitzgerald Kennedy, 35th president
of the United States, visited Dallas.
That's interesting. Also, the number 11
over there. That's the building. Here's
the building from which he was
apparently assassinated from that
window, so they say. There it is, a
little bit larger.
And uh here's the plaque where they have
written what happened over here on
November 22. The building gained the
national notoriety when Lee Harvey
Oswald and somebody did the trouble to
underline allegedly
shot and killed President John F.
Kennedy and uh most people don't believe
that Lee Harvey Oswald shot the
president. The president's car came down
the street. That tree was not yet there
and was apparently shot from that window
over there and it happened approximately
where I'm standing relative to this
picture. Now notice as he comes down
here, he's traveling on this side of the
road. And imagine hordes of people
standing on either side. And here is a
little uphill. And when you go further
into the hall over here, there was a
picket fence. And if you looked from the
picket fence, you could look down onto
the street. And apparently when the
shots were fired, over a hundred people,
including the police, it didn't run this
way, but ran up this embankment towards
the picket fence. Now, why did they run
to the front of the president and not
from behind the president? Apparently,
they say Lee Harvey Oswald shot him from
behind and he was the only one who shot
and he shot from behind and he hit him
over here. A very very fantastic shot by
the way if it is so. It only has a
little problem. The president's head
didn't go forward. It went backwards and
he hit it hit him here in the throat.
And there was a small entry wound in the
front and a huge one in the back. So
from where was he hit? From the front or
from the back? He was hit from the
front. Not only that, there were shots
from other places along the side and
there was an intercalation which all hit
the president. There is even evidence
that the driver himself who happened to
be left-handed were rotated and shot the
president himself with a pistol as well.
He had multiple shots
of the witnesses that ran towards the
picket fence. Over a hundred of them,
almost all of them except for one or two
ladies who were ridiculed
were assassinated themselves.
Is that not strange? Wouldn't you think
that was strange if all the witnesses
died strangely?
Well, this is one of the biggest
coverups that probably ever occurred.
Here's the picket fence. And when you're
looking there, that's how it was.
Someone behind the picket fence would
shoot and this would be the view from
the picket fence. I'm now pretending to
be there. I took these pictures myself.
And the cross would be there. So he
would shoot the president at this short
distance and hit him from the side
fronts. Now it's interesting that the
president's head jerked to his back and
to his left b like that. That means that
he must have been shot from the front
side, right? Isn't that logical? All
right. Now, am I saying this or is this
public knowledge? This is public
knowledge. And yet, it is denied by
government because they have one
culprit, Lee Harvey Oswald. There's the
place where he died, straight shot from
the picket fence.
Now, let's have a look how JF Kennedy
died. and let's look at the television
um production of this issue and then you
make your own uh opinion if we can have
the sound on.
Let's go back to that day in Dallas. The
day was November 22nd, the time shortly
before noon. At first, the crowds were
thick, but as the motorcade approached
Di Plaza, it was here that the motorcade
violated the Secret Service's own rules.
As the car turned, it slowed from 40 mph
to seven. It was precisely then that
gunshots blasted out. For 6 seconds, the
occupants of Kennedy's car were struck
by bullets. Kennedy grasped for his
throat.
>> Grasp my throat.
>> Kennedy's head exploded, driven with
great force backwards and to the left.
Then and only then did the president's
car accelerate and speed off.
Lyndon Johnson, the new president,
ordered a federal commission to
investigate the crime. The Warren
Commission had given us the official
version. Lee Harvey Oswald had acted
alone. But if all three shots had come
from behind, then why did the
president's head fly backwards? Why did
so many people, including policemen, run
not towards the book depository where
Oswald was, but towards the picket
fence?
If the Warren Commission was right, why
does so many witnesses claim to see
something completely different from the
official report? As many as 177 people
died simply from knowing too much. The
moment Kennedy was killed, a massive
cover up went into operation. Witnesses
were threatened and many were killed. in
health interviewed immediately
afterwards.
>> Shots rang out and he grabbed his chest.
There was an interval and then three or
four more shots rang out for that time
the motorcade away.
>> With us now is Jean Hill. He was closer
to the president's car than anyone else
at the time of the shooting. Miss Hill
is a Dallas grade school teacher and has
feared for her life for the last 29
years.
I understand that two men claiming to be
Secret Service agents interrogated you
after the assassination. What were you
asked?
>> They asked me what I had seen. I told
them uh that I'd seen the president hit,
that I saw a shooter from the null and
that I'd heard four to six shots, but
they told me I didn't hear but three
shots.
>> Were you ever interviewed by the war
commission?
>> Oh, yes. I was interviewed by uh Arlland
Spectre who uh well he tried very hard
to discredit everything I said. He
accused me of all kinds of things from
like a shabby marital affair to seeking
publicity to just downright lying.
>> We found the real facts and certainly no
one in the intervening 25 years has
disproved our basic conclusions. It was
Spectre who came up with the so-called
magic bullet theory, which tracks one
bullet going through both Kennedy and
Texas Governor John Connelly. The bullet
was later discovered virtually intact on
Conny's hospital stretcher.
>> The truth had been known, had it come
out, would revealed there was a
conspiracy.
>> Conspiracy to kill the president needed
a scapegoat, a pansy, someone who would
take the blame. There were many things
you weren't supposed to see, like the
paraffin test given to Oswald. It proved
conclusively that Oswald had not fired a
rifle that day. Or the spy camera found
in Oswald's possessions, issued to him
by the US government, or Oswald's letter
to a Mr. Hunt requesting his next
assignment. The only hunt we know of in
this case is Howard Hunt of the CIA, who
shared the same office with Oswald in
New Orleans. The office belonged to Guy
Bannister, formerly with the FBI. Not
only was this address on Oswald's
supposedly pro-castro leaflets, but the
account Oswald used to print the
leaflets belonged to the CIA. Howard
Hunt with the CIA, Guy Banister with the
FBI and Lee Harvey Oswald, all in the
same office.
Kennedy's motorcade was arranged to make
two turns, taking him directly into a
triangulation. The first shot came from
the picket fence. It hit Kennedy in the
throat. The second shot came from the
Dow Tex building next to the book
depository. It entered Kennedy's back.
The third shot came from the southwest
corner of the book depository, 7th
floor. It hit Connelly. The fourth shot
came from the Delex. It narrowly missed,
hit the curb, wounding a bystander.
The fifth and sixth shots were fired
almost simultaneously
from the depository and from the picket
fence. Both at Kennedy in the head. One
from above moving him forward. Then an
instant later one from the front tossing
him back.
Here
you see the passenger in the front
turning back looking at the president.
Instead of jumping back to his system,
he turns forward. The driver is now
rotating. Weapon comes into view and he
fires. You'll see this repeatedly in
these sequences.
Kennedy's been shot in the throat. He's
leaning to his left. The driver now
begins to rotate. His left arm comes
over his right shoulder and he fires.
Now
again, you see the driver rotate. You
see the weapon come into view.
He's rotating again. The weapon is in
view. He fires.
Can clearly see his head turning and the
his arm and the weapon extending into
view over his right shoulder. One of the
first activities of William Greer after
the presidential limousine arrived at
Parkland Hospital was to attain a bucket
and a sponge and water and begin to wash
the blood and brains off of the
presidential limousine. There's a new
theory about the assassination of John
F. Kennedy. A government scientist says
police audio tapes provide new evidence
of a second gunman. If it could be
proved that the sound on the tape was a
gunshot and that in fact it came from
the grassy null, then it would provide
some evidence that there was a second
gunman in addition to Lee Harvey Oswald.
But so far few who agree with the
conclusion made by Thomas.
>> Hello.
>> Yes, Rick. Go ahead, please.
>> Yes. I'd like to know why it's taken uh
so long for this information and the
truth to be exposed.
>> In the first place, it hasn't been
exposed yet, and I don't think it ever
will be. Secrecy in government is
designed for one purpose and one purpose
only. Not to keep the enemy or the
opposition from knowing what's going on,
but to keep the American people from
knowing what is going on. and all the
evidence that exists or might have
existed that would implicate uh the
government in Kennedy's assassination,
you can be sure that evidence is now
destroyed.
So even if everything is released now,
the chances of solving the Kennedy
assassination and attaching the blame to
the guilty parties is almost impossible.
Kennedy was changing the status quo but
decided he could no longer trust the
CIA.
>> He was transferring covert operations
directly to the joint chiefs of staff.
Shortly after that he fired Alan Delos
who had been the director of central
intelligence since 1953.
>> Kennedy continued to make enemies as he
pulled back from world confrontation.
He ordered US troops out of Vietnam.
This was an incident that took place.
>> Well,
you saw that driver rotate. If you could
see it, it was very difficult. You could
see his head go back. You could see all
these things. Vatican assassins says,
"But after the failure of the Bay of
Pigs invasion, President Kennedy changed
due to his betrayal by the Jesuit
Council of Foreign Relations in the
person of Mcj Bundy. He sought to break
the CIA into a thousand pieces." Now the
CIA would be like the SS. Why break
that? Then he called for a return to
America's currency to the gold standard.
That was a major problem that would stop
the Federal Reserve. And another thing
that he said, he said, "I will separate
church and state." I think that was a
big mistake that he made in the eyes of
the Jesuits.
Remember that Lyola said, "Finally, let
all with such artfulness gain the
ascendant over princes, noblemen, and
magistrates of every place, that they
may be ready at our beck, even to
sacrifice their nearest relations and
most intimate friends when we say it is
for our interest and advantage."
That's fascinating.
We know, of course, that Jacqueline
Kennedy was raised in a Jesuit convent,
but let's leave it there.
One of Nixon's main speech writers
during three whole years was Jesuit
father the Reverend John McClaclin who
wrote Nixon speeches at a salary of
33,000 a year which was a lot of money
at that time and the next presidents one
of the next ones Gerald Ford there's his
own signature 33°ree Freemason I took
this picture myself in the Masonic Lodge
there he signs it 33°ree Freemason
these people are not who they say they
are and And when we look at him and we
look at these handshakes that they have
and uh the holy alliance between the
papacy and the United States of America.
This is by the way a signal picture and
Reagan appointed this man to be u
representative to the Vatican. So by
1987 Pope John Paul visits the United
States. President Reagan meets him and
he says as you exhort us we will listen.
This is not separation of church and
state. For with all our hearts, we yearn
to make this good land better still. The
Pope is quoted as saying, "I come as a
friend, a friend of America and of all
Americans, Catholics, Orthodox, Jews,
all men of good will." Well,
interesting. Here he is together. This,
by the way, also a Masonic signal
picture, but we won't go into the
details. That's also a Masonic signal
picture. We won't go into those details.
How do they plan their trips? Let's ask
them. Here's Ronald Reagan planning his
trip to
this president of Russia.
>> Then in September, Gorbachov proposed a
presummit meeting in Reikovit, Iceland.
Washington agreed. The astrologer fixed
the time and the date of departure and
at 9:45 on October the 9th, Reagan flew
to Reikovic.
>> For instance, if you have very bad
Saturn, you should cultivate Jupiter. So
that
>> wow is now acting like Nebuchadnezzar.
It's called the astrologers to tell us
when this meeting should take place. You
know, the 11th is a very important date.
Presidents die on it. Buildings collapse
on it. It's very interesting.
My pope, Pope Paul II, I confirm for you
as the pope of my secret. The Pope about
whom I spoke to the children during the
apparitions, the pope of my love and my
sorrow. This is what Mary apparently
said to the children at Fatima.
This is the pope of the secret or this
is the the Mary predicted that he would
have an assassination. This pope and the
modern channels through father goi say
that this is the pope of the promise.
Well, Malachi Martin in the keys of this
blood, this uh is a pontipical work,
writes, "Clearly, the new agenda,
heaven's agenda, the grand design of God
for a new world order had begun, and
Pope John Paul would stride now in the
arena of the millennium endgame as
something more than a geopolitical giant
of his age. He was and remains the
serene and confident servant of the
grand design." There's another Masonic
language. He's going to be the head
honcho, the main man.
All this bloodshed, all these wars in
Germany. What happened? What did the war
do in Germany? The Second World War in
Germany, the north of Germany was
devastated. It was firebombed, which was
illegal according to all conventions.
They threw firebombs on the north of
Germany. Hamburg was gutted by
firebombs. Now firebombs don't just
destroy military targets. What do they
destroy? They burn human beings alive.
So it was targeted to destroy the
people. And then East Germany, the
entire Protestant conclave was cut out
and handed over to Soviet Russia for two
generations of enforced atheism. Today
there's no Protestant left anymore.
Protestantism has been destroyed. The
Orthodox Church has been subjugated. All
of them are subject to Rome. Millions of
Serbians died. Millions.
It has been a slaughter in the last
centuries such as this world has not
seen. Why? To gain full control of the
world. Here is Gerard Newkerk states,
"Over the last two decades, in
particular during the Reagan years and
the last two with George W, the United
States is looking less like a democracy
and more like a highly evolved fascist
creature." Isn't that interesting? I'm
not saying this, I'm just reading it.
Devoid of the idioyncrasies and
shortcomings of its progenitors where
they practice this. This form of fascism
has a propaganda machine that is unar
arguably the most efficient the world
has ever seen.
We are in an interesting time frame. And
here you see George Bush with a with a
pope. Here you see the prime minister of
England with the pope. All these
thousand points of light 33°ree
Freemason skull and bones member
Illuminatist 33°ree Freemason with the
pope and now let's have a look at this
picture here is President George W. Bush
with the pope under the picture of
Ignatius Lyola
who's going to be the great spiritual
leader of the new world order. Please
note this picture. The pope sits on the
altar of Korazim. This is when he
visited
uh Jerusalem and Israel recently.
Israel. The backdrop depicts Christ with
an open book that reads, "Love your
enemies. I will come soon." What else do
you see on his throne?
An upside down cross. There's the pope
too with an upside down cross symbol of
Lucifer's victory
over Jesus. This is a sad state of
affairs. And we looked at the teachings
of illuminism. We looked at the
teachings of the Masonic order of the
secret societies. And we saw that
Lucifer was their god. They said so
themselves.
And what do we have to do? come out of
her, my people, that you not be
partakers of her sins.
I believe that we are on the threshold
of history. I believe that the final
events are unfolding
and I believe that we need have no fear
because God said
that he would give them the opportunity
to show their true colors. The final
apostasy against God will end in the
greatest victory the universe has ever
seen and the kingdom of God will soon be
ushered in. If you thought
that this was long in the future, I have
news for you. It is at the door. Jesus
is coming soon. Thank you.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
baby.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.